justement parce que c'est l'anniversaire
de nikos on va jouer tout de suite à vis
hélium c'est parti d'une gueule
[Musique]
vichy zélium les loups c'est très simple
et chroniqueurs ont tous préparé une
chanson
malheureusement le chroniqueur j'aurais
pas validé comme dans la série où comme
dans le titre de booba devra faire ce
qu'on appelle une shy'm dans les
feuillages et alors qu'est ce que cette
fin si je n'aime pas les projecteurs ou
je ne sais plus merci on va démarrer pas
le premier il va donc prendre de
l'hélium et nous faire à johnny hallyday
c'est le retour de benjamin castaldi
johnny c'est parti buluk gardiennage par
calais pas très bas je suis moi sorti un
lot de la cage
excuse moi ta gueule ça c'est du johnny
du corps il a eu cette coiffure très
petit non mais mais pourquoi ta mis sa
rhétorique mais moi tu fais johnny
bamiléké pas de bananes y avait pas il
n'y avait pas de feta free mireille
mathieu spider man
ah bah je vais changer a donné nos bon
allez vas t'asseoir merci c'est validé
et était là mais sur le reste serré
merci tout était beau mais franchement
il a fait un peu de muscu suisse oui
j'ai vu j'ai vu j'ai vu le m arrête sur
ces photos et les épaules il est
magnifique et je suis content de te voir
je me relève le cheveu aplomb et les
baux à oui regardez comme il est beau le
castaldi g2 castaldi j'ai laissé pousser
castaldi car n'ayons aucun salle du
thelle seul carlos est intervenu ce nom
cetera johnson merci merci mais ça
rigolait était magnifique gras françois
thébaud et je rappelle castaldi qui sera
de nouveau papa pour la 22
pourquoi ce sera courant quoi cour
enjoint tu seras début septembre début
septembre entre ronald lalalalala en
même temps que votre chômage par mon
bébé il sera l'année prochaine va
castaldi bien entendu tant qu'il
n'ouvrira pas les yeux on profitera lui
les chéris allez on accueille tout de
suite
sylvie vartan c'est isabelle morini-bosc
isabelle morini bosc
[Musique]
en cas d'un garçon j'ai peur qu'un
blouson année capoue soir ont comme un
gars encore aller acheter son intention
avec comme un garçon va t'asseoir ni
athée soir mais pourquoi tu mets pas ta
perruque entièrement quoi tu l'as des
cheveux dépassé on m'a dit que ça allait
très bien non mais franchement tu ça qui
avait tu ressembles à thurso pourrais tu
ressembles à cyndi lauper la femme la
femme dort un look ou alors tu te disent
et c'est là qu'on se rend compte que
sans public
eh ben vous êtes encore plus triste vous
vous êtes maquiller dans le noir je sais
pas vous avez toujours électricité chez
vous merci allez on va accueillir
maintenant celle qu'on appelle kelly en
france et paye là en tunisie
ces deux cas il est c'est parti tac tac
tac mais il ya c'est pas toc toc toc ce
droit mais je sais mais je sais mais je
ne sais quoi et c'est bon c'est bon
allez bon serait pas reconnu la chanson
c'est une catastrophe on dirait régine
allez merci avec alex était une ânesse
première fois est ce qu'on peut la
mettre
c'est pas le refrain des scellés sol où
c'est la feuille à bissau où quand tu
demandes une chanson il te la mettre du
début césaire ils n'ont pas calé il te
met l'intro cette bande norman jordaan
merci région nord pas ce que j'appelle
nourdine quel producteur lui sont ils
faits jusqu'au feu oui au directoire et
sur des faibles
allez c'est parti on va passer à aux
chroniqueurs préférés de kenza c'est
jean-michel même quand elles avoir cassé
la doit à casser la voix je peux plus
croire tout ce qu'a écrit sur les baies
tu regardes tu veux plus voir est ça
fait combattre et aux excuses m'en
excuse mais arrête ça fait combien
d'années qui fait de la télé disons tu
sais pas que c'est la caméra qui pour
garder quand même à bras j'ai oublié mes
toiles à ces rigolos
on dirait aimé qu'un rapport avec
patrick branlant dire et je me dirais
didier bourdon dans le space company de
monaco non mais rien à voir c'est raté
ça oui c'est raté oui je le dis là là ce
côté là c'est dégueulasse
ici se sont battus ici là ça n'a pas
changé d'avis mais je crois quoi alors
tu as changé d'avis wales elle te quitte
voilà merci allez on va cueillir
maintenant valérie bédard
c'est parti o les papas mais qu'elle
passa à ce qu'il paraît tuque au havre à
toi y'a pas moi et tchadiens ouais c'est
pas sa carte hadjadj à valérie oui pour
moi c'est toi qui a gagné ni perdu mais
on va les régler
traître et toi voilà ça bosse c'est
français c'est beau c'est carré c'est
benhaim c'est ce qu'on aimera bon bénin
brabo points d'eau perruque à oui ben
hiba oui bah oui mr c -b naim et eti
génial j'adore
attention le dernier
je rappelle qu'ils livrent à rungis la
journée et il fait
le mucus comme on dit le gugusse chez
nous l'après midi c'est notre ami
raymond vall illustre sa caméra abouti
ça c'était soprano ça ça c'était soprano
ça arrête je peux tu peux nous leur
faire tout de suite on mieux bah on n'en
doute pas ça fait partie de ma vie dure
teldar cas ça y est je vois lé
technicien les gâter vos cerner je vous
lis normalement pour voir ça c'est
double pige françois les équipes leur
nom à papa beinheim qui a énormément
laquelle louzac peuvent regarder bois et
bois du bon gars j'ai plus de ballons
intéressants
rappelle-toi par toi